he visit a family in the pool where last  year's earthquake continues to be felt  my name is Nero's and I live in car  mando and afterload quick i live in a  tent I can you see in my tent come I'm  I'm living here and with my father  mother brothers and uncle and all all in  here and I'm very happy because my my  family in here that's my temple little  temple and here is how God and I believe  in God and God his help me and all my  family in here  and that's ticka ticka coming festival  and we put that dick ass just like that  tikka pudding this is my mother now  cooking t he is my father and he had one  little soft and just like that and yard  puddi puddi heiress Susan  it's booty and food is very tasty and we  eat with that inhale pull its hope and  we put in here water and water and we  eat it's very tasty also it's can you  eat that can you test thank you for  visiting us and that was my tent and  goodbye